RUSSIAN SHILLINGS, AND TO THE
NORTH, THE CONVOY INCHES CLOSER
TO UKRAINE'S CAPITAL.
BENJAMIN HALL IS LIVE IN KIEV,
UKRAINE, WITH THE LATEST.
>> WHAT YOU JUST LAID OUT COME
OF THIS WAR IS ESCALATING,
HEATING UP.
THE NORTH, SOUTH, EAST, THE
RUSSIANS -- THEY SURROUNDED THIS
CITY, AND ODESSA.
KIEV IS BEING APPROACHED MORE
GRADUALLY BY THE RUSSIANS.
WE HAVE SEEN THIS CONFLICT,
NUMBER OF VIDEOS THAT HAVE COME
OUT.
THERE ARE SOME INCREDIBLE VIDEOS
ON SOCIAL MEDIA AND ELSEWHERE.
>> JUST ONE
-
NOT BEING DOCUMENTED.
THERE ARE COUNTLESS OTHER STORES
TO GO WITH THAT AS WELL.
ANOTHER SCHOOL WAS HIT WITH
THAT -- HALF OF THE CITY LEFT
DESTROYED, 22 CIVILIANS
DESTROYED IN ANOTHER BOMBING
PRICKS AT THE KIEV TODAY, A FEW
CHILDREN KILLED, SON KILLED AT
HOME AND IN THEIR CARS.
RUSSIA IS TIGHTENING THE NOOSE
ON THE CAPITAL.
THE RUSSIANS HAVE BEEN RELEASING
THIS VIDEO OVERNIGHT THAT SHOWS
TANKS AND ARMORED VEHICLES
CROSSING INTO THE KIEV REGION,
AND THEY HAVE -- JUST OUTSIDE.
TODAY -- RALLIES, GATHERING,
PEOPLE ARE IN EUROPEAN
COUNTRIES.
THEY HELD A MINUTE OF SILENCE
FOR THOSE WHO HAD DIED.
SPEAKER COME TO THE STREETS,
SUPPORT UKRAINE, OR FREEDOM.
THIS IS A VICTORY OF LIGHT OVER
DARKNESS, A VICTORY OF GOOD OVER
EVIL.
>> TONIGHT IN KIEV, WE'VE SEEN
MORE ACTION THAN THE LAST COUPLE
OF NIGHTS.
SOME ARTILLERY FLASHES ON THE
HORIZON, A SHORT GUN BATTLE --
RUSSIAN FORCES ARE MOVING
TOWARDS THE CITY ARID ONLY A
MATTER OF TIME BEFORE THEY START
PALMING IT MORE HEAVILY.
THE STREETS RIGHT NOW ARE EMPTY.
PEOPLE ARE PREPPING, THEY ARE
READY.
DEFENSES ARE UP, AND RUSSIA HAS
MADE IT CLEAR THAT IF THEY FIGHT
COUNTER RESISTANCE THEY WILL
CRUSH IT.
PEOPLE ARE BRAVE, MOTIVATED, SO
WE WILL SEE TH